bonsoir et bienvenue dans savoure
regardera vite vous retrouver notre
grand témoin ce soir c'est vous Aurélien
Pradier le trublion de la droite tout
juste émincé du poste de numéro 2 des
républicains on va revenir sur vos
positions sur la forme des retraites
elles ont fait couler beaucoup d'encre
le texte a été adopté en commission au
Sénat aujourd'hui mais on va aussi
parler sécheresse votre département du
Lot est agricole et vous étiez au salon
de l'agriculture toute la journée mais
on commence avec l'Afrique Emmanuel
Macron en termes de main une tournée de
quatre jours sur le continent africain
10 ans après l'arrivée dans la liesse
des soldats français au Mali les
drapeaux tricolores sont désormais
brûlés dans plusieurs grandes capitales
africaines francophones alors comment la
France a perdu la bataille de
l'influence en Afrique quel avenir pour
les relations franco-africaines c'est
notre grand débat dans un instant avec
nos invités avant de retrouver à 20h15
les parties pris de nos affranchis et
puis Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu
ce soir vous me suivez Aurélien Pradier
[Musique]
une histoire franco-africaine ce soir
six mois après le retrait des troupes
françaises du Mali et 10 jours à peine
après celui du Burkina Faso notre pays a
perdu beaucoup d'influence son Afrique
on va essayer de comprendre pourquoi ce
soir maladresse française manipulation
russe ou aveuglement d'une ancienne
puissance coloniale bonsoir thomasillou
et merci d'être là à vous présider la
commission de la défense à l'Assemblée
le chef de l'État a fait un discours à
l'Élysée hier soir il veut un nouveau
partenariat militaire en Afrique on va
en parler vous êtes député renaissance
du Rhône bonsoir Nadège à bomangoli et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
député la France insoumise de
Seine-Saint-Denis vous présidez le
groupe d'amitié à l'Assemblée France
Gabon où se rend dès demain c'est la
première étape le président français et
puis vous êtes né à Brazzaville au Congo
où se rend également le chef de l'État
on en parlera bonsoir Pascal Hérault
ravi de vous accueillir sur ce plateau
vous êtes journaliste à l'opinion où
vous suivez les questions africaines
auteur avec Antoine laser de ce livre
qui va s'afficher le piège africain de
Macron publié chez Fayard enfin bonsoir
aminatanyakate et bienvenue vous êtes
avocate Franco malienne porte-parole
d'Europe Écologie Les Verts et vous
étiez à Bamako en 2013 au moment où les
soldats français sont arrivés Aurélien
Pradier je crois savoir que l'Afrique
vous passionne donc n'hésitez pas à
intervenir vous nous direz ce que vous
pensez de la vision nouvelle ou pas de
de la relation franco-africaine des
manuels Macron mais d'abord on va
planter le décor Stéphane blackovski
France Afrique est-ce la fin de
l'influence il a deux secondes pour
répondre à la question c'est le chrono
de Blacko pour commencer
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir à toutes et
tous je me retourne comme chaque soir le
président français s'est exprimé hier
soir à l'Élysée
le président Macron nous a expliqué
qu'il voulait donc réinventer la
relation de la France notre beau pays
avec le continent africain donc pourquoi
pas au début d'un nouveau quinquennat
c'est normal d'avoir un grand projet le
problème c'est que c'était le même
projet au début de son premier
quinquennat en 2017 souvenez-vous il
était à Ouagadougou devant 800 étudiants
et voilà deux extraits de ce qu'il avait
dit à ce moment-là des moments forts
je suis une génération de français pour
qui les crimes de la colonisation
européenne sont incontestables et font
partie de notre histoire notre
responsabilité n'est pas de rester dans
ce passé
mais de vivre l'aventure pleine et
entière de cette génération alors comme
quoi les bonnes intentions ne font pas
forcément une bonne politique puisque 6
ans plus tard Emmanuel Macron lui ne
peut plus remettre les pieds au Burkina
Faso donc à Ouagadougou puisque les
puccistes qui se sont emparés du pouvoir
ont demandé à l'armée française de
partir mais c'est aussi le cas en
Roumanie ou les Français soldats
français ont été poussés d'or ils ont
aussi été poussés dehors en Centrafrique
donc on est plus vraiment avec l'armée
française avec ce fameux gendarme de
l'Afrique qui est incarnait à un moment
donc il y a bien sûr le poids du passé
colonial mais il y a aussi l'activité
incessante de la Russie qui joue là
dessus en diffusant des clips sur les
réseaux sociaux on connaît leur peau
aujourd'hui donc je vous en montre un
qui est diffusé régulièrement c'est
assez simpliste la France est un
représentée par ce gros rat qui a grossi
en se nourrissant des réserves de
l'Afrique le groupe backgrin arrive pour
lui tenir tête ou même lui éclater la
tête disons-le et puis bien sûr à la fin
de la conclusion vous la connaissez les
Russes sont très sympas on peut prendre
le petit déjeuner le matin avec eux
c'est toujours très agréable alors ça
paraît vraiment simpliste et en même
temps quand on regarde une carte on voit
l'influence réelle que peut avoir
aujourd'hui la Russie regardez ça c'est
en sombre les pays qui se sont abstenus
de condamnés à la vision de l'Ukraine
par la Russie notamment on voit l'Angola
ou le Congo ou le président
se rendra demain donc
vous voyez que en faisant ce choix là
ils se sont en fait alignés sur l'un
mais surtout sur la Chine qui elle aussi
à un poids de plus en plus important en
Afrique on va montrer sur une carte qui
n'a rien à voir avec la Chine qui nous
rappelle le passé de la France sur le
continent en rouge c'est les positions
françaises on pourra peut-être ajouter
le Congo belge où on est francophone ça
fait une très grosse zone d'influence
même après les indépendants en fait
cette influence a continué ça la France
sacrifice et je vous montre cette carte
là vous allez voir que
en 2000 tous les pays en bleu sur cette
carte avec comme premier partenaire
commercial la France et oui ça
correspond à peu près à l'Afrique
occidentale 20 ans plus tard on en est
où et bien mondialisation oblige ça que
c'est partout dans le monde c'est
désormais la Chine qui commerce en
priorité avec l'Afrique donc je peux
illustrer ça si vous voulez de manière
un peu amusante je sais pas si ça vous
fera sourire mais voyez dans le temps
c'était les présidents français qui
arrivaient on faisait des timbres pour
chacune de leurs visites pour leur
rendre hommage bon c'est un peu changé
aujourd'hui quand la Centrafrique
publique s'éteindre parce que voilà
c'est un hommage au président chinois
alors comment faire pour tenir tête à la
Russie et à la Chine en Afrique faut-il
être agressif non pas du tout c'est ce
qu'elle dit hier soir président de
Macron pour éviter la répétition de
l'histoire il existe une autre voie
que nous poursuivons désormais depuis 6
ans une autre voie qui consiste à ne pas
réduire l'Afrique à un terrain de
compétition ou de rente
donc voilà depuis 6 ans la France
cherche à maintenir son influence sans
passer pour une puissance colonisatrice
manifestement c'est pas évident parce
qu'on n'y a pas toujours bien réussi
mais heureusement vous avez des
spécialistes et ils ont peut-être des
solutions parce que moi je sens que
c'est très compliqué cette histoire
on y est on y va Thomas gassiou pour
commencer c'est vrai qu'en grossissant à
peine le trait on a l'impression qu'en
disant la France en tout cas pour la
partie saélienne est passé de héros à
Paria il y a un sentiment anti-français
quels sont ces causes profondes pour
vous déjà sur l'analyse une risque de
fragmentation entre le Nord et le Sud
vous avez montré les pays qui sont
abstenus à l'ONU sur la condamnation de
l'agression russe en Ukraine ce ne sont
pas spécifiquement des pays de l'Afrique
francophone d'une part donc oui
effectivement il y a ce risque il y a un
problème actuellement sur les pays où la
France a mené des opérations militaires
qui ont parfois été incomprises
notamment au Sahel ou parfois elles ont
eu le qui ont alors qui ont parfois des
responsabilisé les autorités locales
dans leur capacité à trouver des
solutions aux problèmes locaux et les
populations se retournent vers l'armée
française et la France qui a peut-être
globalement manqué d'humidité en disant
vous êtes là depuis 8 ans la situation
n'est toujours pas ne s'améliore
toujours pas comment se fait-il que ça
continue alors que la France dispose de
moyens est-ce que la France aurait un
nageur dans le cacher et les régimes
locaux se sont un peu appuyés sur la
soi-disant ou s fois de la France pour
dire que la situation ne s'améliorera
pas quand je me déplace ailleurs en
Afrique j'étais récemment à Kinshasa en
RDC il y a une envie de France et par
contre
parce que l'est dans l'Est la situation
ne s'améliore pas c'est actuellement les
troubles de l'ONU qui feront l'objet
d'un rejet de la part de la population
donc moi pour ma part je ne parlerai pas
de rejet global de la France relativiser
se passe sur certaines zones où on a
besoin effectivement de faire évoluer
notre présence d'où les annonces du
président de la République Nadège à
revenir tout à l'heure sur le choix des
pays qui est pas faut forcément voilà
très cohérent entre du président
français mais sur
Emmanuel Macron c'est un président très
jeune il avait tout pour au fond tourner
la page du passé colonial est-ce que
pour vous ce rejet de la France c'est
celui de son Président ou ça va bien
au-delà
d'abord je pense que ça va bien au-delà
je pense que en fait on arrive à une
situation aujourd'hui qui est aussi la
conséquence des termes de la relation
entre la France et certains États en
Afrique particulièrement en Afrique
francophone je tiens d'abord à souligner
quand même qu'on parle souvent de
sentiments anti-français je pense que
les peuples n'ont pas de problème entre
eux donc c'est il y a rien contre les
Français mais je pense c'est davantage
sur les politiques
a évoqué la déresponsabilisation
l'État malien bon je pense que c'est un
peu facile je pense que quand il y a une
présence qui est d'abord demandé qu'à la
fin elle est rejeter au bout de 10 ans
mais là c'est massif mais c'est quand
même on avait quand même des signaux
jusque là il y a des erreurs françaises
qui ont été commises aussi un manque de
lisibilité des objectifs en fait quand
ça dure autant de temps il faut qu'en
fait dans la relation entre les peuples
et les États les objectifs soient
partagés et ça fait également écho à un
manque de lisibilité également en France
puisque il y a des domaines réservés on
le sait dans la Constitution en
françaises mais les débats sur les
objectifs militaires stratégiques au
Mali ont été très peu pesés en France et
très peu discuter par la représentation
nationale pour se faire une idée un peu
de de ce qu'on y fait et de vous
rappeler d'ailleurs pour ceux qui nous
regardent il y a des débats sur les
opérations extérieures mais il y a pas
de vote à l'Assemblée nationale des
député sur les engagements de la France
c'est le très peu si vous récupérez si
j'ose dire si vous comparez
les opérations extérieures sont débattus
on a un vrai déficit démocratique et du
coup bah c'est la même chose là-bas
parce qu'elle est comment vous voyez
vous ce rejet de la France est-ce qu'il
faut l'imputer
à ses 10 ans de présence militaire
française disons c'est long c'est
forcément à la fin vécu comme une
occupation
comme une armée d'occupation
Serval a été très bien acceptée au début
et puis après on avait qu'on s'était on
disait d'ailleurs les militaires
français ont décidé d'arrêter Serval
très rapidement pourquoi parce qu'il
voulait que ça reste comme un succès
militaire dans l'histoire prestigieuse
de l'armée française mais pour revenir à
votre question il y a des raisons nous
font des raisons historiques qui sont
liées à l'histoire coloniale de la
France certaines exactions qu'on a pu
commettre dans ces pays au fait qu'on a
une présence militaire dans beaucoup de
pays depuis l'indépendance et pour une
pour la pour la jeunesse africaine ça
devient insupportable on l'avait vécu au
moment des événements de Côte d'Ivoire
déjà à l'époque avec des manifestations
devant la base française il y a cette
monnaie aussi à rimée à l'euro dont le
président
il a essayé de faire évoluer la relation
monétaire mais là il est pris un peu
dans un piège parce que c'est les
présidents africains qui veulent pas se
départir du franc CFA puis il y a des
raisons plus conjoncturelles qui sont
liées à l'actualité qui sont liées à la
guerre en Ukraine qui sont liées à la
formationnel la compétition avec avec la
Russie sur sur le continent avec des
structures avec des officines comme
Wagner qui font un tapage avec une lutte
informationnelle avec des trolls avec et
qui réactive tout ce passé colonial de
la France ou tout ce qu'on a pu mal
faire sur sur le continent dernière
chose
je pense que c'est un phénomène assez
urbain je sais pas si à l'échelle de
toute l'Afrique
et des campagnes surtout il y a je crois
qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres
préoccupations les préoccupations
quotidiennes c'est pas l'influence de la
France ou ce que la France fait bien ou
de mal la préoccupation quotidienne
c'est trouver son pain quotidien nourrir
ses enfants et puis bien les éduquer
Aminata Niakate vous vous y étiez à
Bamako en 2013
on disait que Bamako les djihadistes les
terroristes allaient marcher sur la
capitale au Mali racontez-nous quel
souvenir vous vous avez gardé de ce
moment là bah c'est vrai que c'était
assez particulier parce que moi je viens
de la région du Sud-Ouest donc j'avais
passé 15 jours dans ma cambrousse un peu
coupée du monde je rentre à la capitale
et puis on écoute on écoute France 24 et
on découvre que Ben que les dji sont à
2h de Bamako etc que la France avait
décidé 60 débats à l'Assemblée de venir
d'intervenir mais c'est vrai que tout le
monde était extrêmement soulagé il y a
même eu des gens qui ont prénommé leur
leurs enfants François Hollande donc je
sais pas s'ils s'emmorent
donc et moi même j'étais sur le moment
j'étais très très soulagée parce que on
entendait ces récits de main couper etc
de lapidation à mort et on avait aucune
envie que cette espèce d'alliance de la
carpe et du lapin parce qu'il y avait
ACMI qui c'était un peu détruant
trafiquants de drogue trafic de d'êtres
humains etc alliés avec
en sardines qui sont pour dire un pan
islamisme et avec le MNLA qui voulait
l'indépendance du Nord donc c'est
vraiment l'alliance de la carpe et du
lapin rejoint par des mercenaires
libyens qui descendaient donc c'était
assez effrayant et cette question
terroriste elle est dans d'autres pays
aussi aujourd'hui
manipulation russe derrière ce sentiment
français vous avez vécu au Mali vous
l'avez vu venir vous cette montée en
puissance de Moscou et de cette milice
Wagner alors moi je j'avoue que je suis
tombée des nues mais alors c'est vrai
qu'il y a toujours eu des liens plus ou
moins intenses avec les Russes il y
avait par exemple une coopération
de la coopération un peu étudiante enfin
il y avait des jeunes qui allaient
étudier en Russie de nombreux cadres
c'est plutôt elle est plutôt l'élite
parce que c'était pas la portée de
toutes les liens entre
certains pays dont le Mali c'est ralenti
plutôt à la chute de l'URSS mais ça
s'est réaccéléré depuis deux trois ans
enfin ça accéléré et donc aujourd'hui
donc au début du mois il y a le
diplomate enfin le mystère le ministre
des Affaires étrangères qui est venu au
Mali je crois que c'était jamais arrivé
faire
quand on les voit ces films là parce que
c'est fou c'est extrêmement paternalisme
quand même quand on regarde ça c'est des
dessins animés parce que c'est pourquoi
ça marche non ça marche je pense je suis
pas sûr que ça marche ça c'est un peu
caricatural etc et je pense que
peut-être que la c'est peut-être une
mauvaise stratégie de com parce que les
Maliens ils sont pas stupides non plus
et ils voient bien que c'est hyper
caricatural ce genre de choses donc je
suis pas certaine que ça marche en tout
cas ces dessins animés
guerre informationnelle il y a quand
même quelque chose qui prend et c'est
pas que le Mali il y en a aussi en
République centrafricaine il y en a au
Burkina bien sûr l'Afrique redevient une
terre de compétition et justement tout
le discours du Président c'est de dire
nous ne considérez pas l'Afrique comme
une carte compétition effectivement
pendant la guerre froide les Russes
étaient très présent d'un point de vue
militaire d'un point de vue économique
mais il veut le REF de l'Afrique une
carte de compétition et les régimes
j'allais dire défaillants font appel
avec nerf la société Wagner avant tout
pour protéger pour être une assurance
vie pour leur propre régime et cette
société pour justifier son intervention
effectivement utilise le champ
informationnel pour tenter de convaincre
la population que les Français sont là
avec un agent d'Akashi pour mieux
justifier des exections en Afrique
mercenaires qui commet des actions qui
aujourd'hui sont documentées que ce soit
en Centrafrique que ce soit au Mali je
voulais juste revenir sur deux points
tout à l'heure on a parlé de
l'intervention du Parlement dans la
décision des opérations heureusement
qu'en 2013 le Parlement n'a pas dû voter
pour engager l'armée française il
fallait décider
par exemple
c'est pour ça qu'en 2013 la France était
quasiment le seul pays à être en mesure
de stopper cette colonne djihadiste
parce que seul elle avait la capacité de
décider rapidement et d'engager
rapidement des des moyens sur le
deuxième point une armée étrangère dans
un pays
étrangers et forcément vu quand elle
vient libérer la population comme une
armée qui libère mais forcément au bout
de 7 ou 8 ans de manière fatale elle est
vue comme une armée d'occupation et
encore une fois ce regard ne porte pas
que sur l'armée française a demandé aux
Maliens ce qu'ils pensent des forces
européennes qui pensent de la minusma
ils ont tous le même regard négatif et
enfin le dernier point que je vous
laisse souligner c'est qu'à mon sens les
promesses du discours de Ouagadougou ont
été tenus en grande partie sur le
français enfin sur l'aspect mémorial sur
la restitution des oeuvres d'art sur
l'accompagnement des jeunes chefs
d'entreprise sur le dialogue avec la
société civile mais effectivement
aujourd'hui on est un peu au milieu du
guet Aurélien Pradier il y a beaucoup de
choses qui ont été qui ont été faites et
en même temps vous citiez le discours de
Ouagadougou je sais pas si vous l'avez
en mémoire et s'adresse à des jeunes et
il y a il fait très chaud et un moment
donné il dit à la jeunesse mais vous me
parlez comme si j'étais l'ancienne
puissance coloniale je ne suis pas là
pour réparer l'électricité et le
président burkinabé se lève
et il y a des rires et il est le
président français lui dit vous vous
partez réparer la clim ça c'est des
petits épisodes c'est du symbolique mais
ça ça laisse des traces la perte
d'influence d'une grande nation comme la
France sur le continent africain mais
ailleurs dans le monde elle n'est pas
liée à un seul épisode c'est une
succession de défaillance et prenons-en
pour nos en quelques-unes de ces
défaillances d'abord la perte de
conquête de la langue observant que sur
le continent africain nous avons perdu
des positions la Francophonie a perdu
des positions la langue tout ça c'est du
soft power si vous me permettez
l'expression pouvoir lent souple qu'on
ne voit pas initialement qui n'est pas
aussi fort qu'une armée ou de des
militaires mais qui a une force
considérable dans les relations sont les
relations culturelles nous avons perdu
les relations culturelles avec le
continent africain depuis des années et
les décisions qui sont prises
aujourd'hui ne suffiront pas à rattraper
ces décennies de retard c'est la
compréhension des chefs d'État entre eux
aussi pardon de dire mais c'est
essentiel épisode vous évoquez je pense
qu'il a fait beaucoup de mal à la
relation diplomatique entre le continent
africain et notre propre pays et puis
ensuite il y a deux trois autres
éléments qui sont pas négligeables
d'abord la concurrence économique oui
l'Afrique n'est pas un terrain de
compétition sauf que d'autres mènent la
compétition en Afrique et qu'au fur et à
mesure que nous nous sommes retirés
alors d'autres ont pris le remplacement
puisqu'il est nouveau c'est la Chine et
la Russie ça l'était pas il y a quelques
décennies du temps de l'URSS mais
désormais il y a là deux acteurs majeurs
qui prennent les positions que la France
a perdu et en fait c'est cette chaîne
continue qui fait que peu à peu nous
avons quitté le continent africain et
que la présence même de militaires comme
ce fut le cas au Mali a été absolument
incomprise parce que il n'y avait plus
aucun lien ne serait-ce que par les
liens culturels qui permettaient de le
comprendre justement on va parler de la
question militaire moins de soldats et
plus d'humilité c'est un peu comme ça
qu'on pourrait résumer le discours
d'Emmanuel Macron à l'Élysée hier soir
Gabon Angola Congo Brazzaville les
République démocratiques du Congo
pourquoi ces pays-là retour sur le
discours du chef de l'État avec Baptiste
garguichardier
une tournée d'Afrique centrale pour un
retour à des fondamentaux Emmanuel
Macron entame les grandes manœuvres dans
un territoire où son influence est
contestée j'en retirerai une seule
exigence celle de faire preuve d'une
profonde humilité dans le viseur une
période reconquête diplomatique alors
quelle stratégie adopté par le président
hier soir lors de son discours il donne
le ton de son nouveau logiciel
l'Afrique n'est pas un carré est encore
moins un continent auquel les Européens
et les Français pourraient dicter un
cadre de développement mais que c'est un
continent où nous devons bâtir
des relations respectueuses équilibrées
responsables le locataire de l'Élysée
veut imprimer à la veille de son voyage
il annonce une réduction des effectifs
militaires
demain notre présence s'inscrira au sein
de base d'école
d'académie qui seront cogérées
fonctionnant avec des effectifs français
qui demeureront mais à des niveaux
moindres et des effectifs africains un
message qu'il portera dès demain lors
d'une visite bien ficelée étalée sur 5
jours d'abord au Gabon en Angola au
Congo puis en RDC trois grandes lignes
au programme les partenariats
économiques la transition écologique ou
encore les questions sécuritaires mais
reste à savoir comment cette visite sera
perçue dans cette partie du continent
car les liens avec l'Afrique centrale se
sont distendus dans cette région
l'influence de la France est
concurrencée par la Chine et la Russie
alors cette visite peut-elle changer la
donne il ne suffira pas
d'effectuer une tournée de cette nature
fuse dans quatre pays de tenir un
discours d'humilité de respect de
révision du dispositif militaire pour
convaincre les Africaines d'un
changement de cap que la France
officielle leur promet maintenant depuis
plus d'un quart de siècle le président
mis sur une démarche collective mais son
entourage a prévenu il devra
indéniablement jongler entre discrétion
et humilité
[Musique]
déjà est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
l'analyse du grand reporter vincentueux
elle est quasi-mornée cette visite de la
coopération de Jacques Chirac entre 86
et 98 nous nous proposait déjà une
nouvelle coopération dans l'égalité la
responsabilité donc il y a rien de
nouveau pratiquement chaque président
qui est arrivé François Hollande Nicolas
Sarkozy ont annoncé la la rupture avec
la France Afrique et nouvelle pratique
mais on revient toujours à la réalité de
notre zone d'influence pourquoi va-t-il
dans ces quatre pays justement
je monte parce que je voulais absolument
qu'on essaie de comprendre ce qu'il y a
une cohérence il y a grand pays qui
n'est pas francophone lusophone c'est le
l'Angola le Gabon la République du Congo
et le RDC est-ce que vous voyez la
cohérence dans ce choix
c'est très simple c'est l'Afrique
centrale c'est une zone historique
d'influence de la présence française et
le pays l'usophone on a quand même
appuyé le rebelle Jonas à vimbi pendant
des années ont joué sur les dota de
tableaux aussi bien avec le parti état
qui était le MPLA qu'avec l'unité du
rebelle jeunesse pourquoi parce qu'il y
a des régies richesses pétrolières très
importantes donc au total donc on
voulait on voulait avoir le République
du Congo c'est exactement la même chose
terre pétrolière le Gabon historiquement
et c'est des pays où on a une présence
et une influence très très historique où
on a même installé à l'époque les chefs
d'État où on les a même délogé à un
moment la République démocratique du
Congo on a eu une influence mais c'est
plus une ancienne colonie belge c'est un
peu différent mais avec Mobutu on
faisait aussi tout un tas d'opérations
en Afrique centrale ou même en Afrique
australe c'est
c'est une c'est des pays qu'on a
délaissé pendant le premier mandat parce
que Emmanuel Macron disait
c'était pas vraiment fréquentable depuis
la chute du mur de Berlin le ventre
démocratisation
d'aller voir des dictateurs non ça a
commencé il y a une succession dynastie
qui a d'autres pays où la malgouvernance
sont des mots mais à l'heure de la
guerre en Ukraine à l'heure où on se
fait mettre dehors du Mali et du Burkina
Faso on a besoin d'aller réaffirmer une
présence française parce que c'est aussi
ce qu'a pas dit Emmanuel Macron hier
c'est que c'est aussi notre statut de
puissance moyenne au Conseil de sécurité
qui est-ce qui tient la plume sur toutes
les résolutions africaines c'est la
France et nos amis américains notre
grand frère américain a tendance à nous
dire ben vous tenez plus votre plaie
carré
Nadège à beau mongoli oui effectivement
il y a une cohérence avec avec cette
visite d'abord la question de la
reconquête d'influence dans un pays
lusophone qui forme un tout du point de
vue géographique géostratégique et puis
du point de vue de ce qu'on peut en
tirer du point de vue des ressources
naturelles le Gabon c'est déjà ça fait
plusieurs mois que plusieurs semaines
que ce sommet plutôt climat et forêt ce
sommet des forêts est annoncé depuis
plusieurs semaines la cause est juste
mais elle est évidemment perçue comme un
soutien au régime
pluri décennale Bongo de Bongo voilà
donc effectivement là il y a une perte
de vitesse de la France sur ces
terrains-là
la Russie bah moi je dis par exemple je
m'appelle Nadège parce que je suis dans
75 et c'était les Russes qui étaient là
la Russie il y a une tradition de
relation avec la Russie parents pour le
Congo Brazzaville mais aujourd'hui dans
le contexte de guerre en Ukraine dans le
contexte de diversification des
partenaires et bien moi je vais
reprendre l'expression d'Anthony laser
l'ogre russe a réveillé le coq français
c'est à dire que là il y a une
temporalité qui peut paraître à
contretemps compte tenu des échéances
électorales qui arrivent et qui peuvent
être vu comme un soutien mais il y a
aussi une temporalité liée aux
événements la guerre en Ukraine et il
faut aussi dire que il y a un certain
nombre de pays africains qui comme tout
un chacun défendent leurs intérêts et
quand on demande à ce que votre des
sanctions il faut peut-être assortir ce
mois de sanctions de compensation pour
les pays en difficulté qu'ils doivent
subir des sanctions donc là il y a une
les questions de risque de famine aussi
qui peuvent toucher certains pays en
Afrique tome agacio on entend ces mots
alors humilité pragmatisme changement de
logiciel sur le sur le plan économique
il dit aux entreprises de se réveiller
aux entreprises françaises mais de voilà
de considérer ça comme une perte de
compétition face à d'autres grandes
puissances est-ce qu'on a les moyens de
de cette reconquête humble
dans les commentaires comment toute
l'histoire poste colonial revient en
permanence et finalement nous empêche de
penser l'avenir quel que soit les
attentions de ce qu'on mène depuis
global contre l'Occident et donc
regarder depuis 2017 les actes qui ont
été posés et à quel point l'ensemble du
système et on a fait partie à quel point
on a du mal à se projeter vers un nouvel
avenir et quand on parle effectivement
de développement économique
effectivement les positions de la France
ont stagné là où la croissance s'est
fait au profit plutôt de nouveaux
compétiteurs puisque nos entreprises
effectivement ont été plutôt dans une
logique de rente et donc le président
leur pousse à dire il y a plus de
précarité français soyez davantage
offensif sur les marchés envoyer vos
meilleurs managers vos meilleurs
dirigeants quand un marché est à 30
soyez offensif sur les marchés et
finalement ce qui essaie de faire le
Président c'est de dire que il faut
qu'on ait une France à la fois qui
respecte ces deux voies en Afrique parce
que elle en a des devoirs en Afrique
effectivement par rapport à son rôle au
Conseil de sécurité par rapport à ses
capacités d'intervention par rapport à
la francophonie au Gabon il y aura un
sommet pour les forêts on est là sur des
pays qui sont
des pays qui sont beaucoup dangereux
mondiaux on va dire se passe et au-delà
de nos devoirs on est là et on l'assume
c'est nouveau pour protéger également
les intérêts qu'on peut avoir et
notamment les intérêts d'ordre
économique la francophonie ou de type
d'intérêt on va terminer avec la
question militaire le mot n'a pas été
prononcé hier enfin c'est quand même un
signal et puis pareil on nous parle de
valorisation des cultures des échanges
moi j'ai envie de dire qu'on c'est un
peu de la science-fiction un étudiant
africain pour venir en France
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il a un visa enfin
pas du tout donc en fait il y a quand
même un disque en Suisse entre la
réalité et puis et les actes en fait du
président Macron la francophonie quand
on développe la culture par exemple et
c'est au sommet de la visite c'est pour
développer la francophonie la RDC je
crois et d'un est un des plus grands
pays francophones si on y va c'est aussi
parce que la Francophonie est présente
sur place donc dans les actes la
francophonie s'inquiète
sécurité parce que là vous parlez du RDC
c'est une des guerres oubliées des plus
dures sur sur la planète on a une
dernière petite carte à vous faire
commenter peut-être parce qu'elle est
Rault ou Thomas gassillou c'est la carte
de la présidence militaire française en
Afrique voilà les les bases permanentes
Sénégal Côte d'Ivoire Gabon alors Tchad
c'est dans le cadre de l'opération
barkham Sahel et Niger djiboutissait à
part on y touche pas mais dans ces
autres bases là elles sont amenées à
diminuer en termes d'effectif militaires
est-ce qu'il faut se réjouir de cela
alors elles ont déjà largement diminué
quand on regarde ces 20 dernières années
dans les années
90 on avait encore 20 000 soldats
prépositionnés en Afrique aujourd'hui on
en a quelques milliers et effectivement
ces bases en vocation encore à réduire
en quantité mais le sujet n'est plus
tellement la quantité de soldat c'est
davantage qu'on en fait et je pense
qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'on passe
d'une logique de soutien à des
opérations extérieures vers une logique
de coopération
la co-construire avec les états locaux
en fonction de leurs besoins on va même
plus parler de base militaire c'est ça
l'idée c'est un mot à proscrire ça c'est
pareil pour le moment ça reste
essentiellement
des arguments il faut voir et c'est pas
nouveau on était en 97 on parlait des
opérations récents renforcement des
capacités africaines avec les militaires
c'est c'est un peu toujours la même
chose on monte en puissance quand on a
besoin d'aller au front et puis après on
voit bien que la présence est contestée
il faut qu'on retrouve un peu d'humilité
donc à chaque fois on repasse par des
par des processus d'africanisation des
forces là on parle de basse conjointe
qui vont être co-géré on va parler
encore un peu d'européanisation pour
diluer
la vérité c'est que les militaires c'est
un théâtre de jeu important l'Afrique ça
l'a toujours été ils veulent rester sur
bas ça permet de rôder des équipements
de former des hommes et ça permet aussi
à la France de garder son influence et
sa capacité d'agir au Conseil de
sécurité donc ça je veux pas laisser un
petit peu
réducteur
même pour recruter les soldats français
pour leur dire vous partirez en OPEX
sur cette question militaire réduire
progressivement les effectifs causés la
question sécuritaire avec les soldats
des pays africains et les soldats
français précisé dans une stratégie
d'influence la difficulté c'est que les
en tout cas au localement les personnes
n'y croient plus vraiment enfin ils sont
en attente d'un vrai partenariat des
galets égales mais pour l'instant on n'y
croit pas il suffit de regarder les
commentaires moi j'ai regardé le
discours d'Emmanuel Macron sur les
réseaux sociaux et les commentaires sont
vraiment terribles terribles c'est donc
je ne sais pas si c'est efficace je ne
sais pas s'il y aller dans la région d'à
côté c'est la bonne réponse pour régler
les problèmes qu'il y a dans la région
dessus je moi je suis assez députée
doivent doivent gérer ces bases et puis
par ailleurs même dans dans la
terminologie employée il y a déjà eu ce
type de ce type d'usage et d'ailleurs
c'est flou on ne sait même pas quelle
base seront concernées etc
on dit quoi par exemple sur sur les
accords de coopération enfin on va pas
ouvrir ce débat qui s'achève on va il y
a quatre jours de visite il y aura
peut-être des précisions avec les
Africains sur le calendrier sur les
effectifs merci beaucoup merci d'être
venu débattre sur LCP de la relation
franco-africaine vous allez rester avec
moi à présent Aurélien Pradier dans une
dizaine de minutes les parties prit de
nos affranchis sont là ils sont en
pleine forme j'aurais mis Baudot la
stratégie d'Emmanuel Macron pourrait
échapper à l'impopulaire réforme des
retraites elles amontagaba va nous
raconter toujours sur les retraites les
retrouvailles des députés à l'Assemblée
après le pugilat dans l'hémicycle et
puis Brandon warrett et ses archives va
revenir sur la fin de partie de Noël le
grec le patron de la FFF mais d'abord on
parle de vous et de vos ambitions
politiques vous avez été je le disais
l'une des grandes voix dans l'hémicycle
sur les retraites qui n'a pas plu à Éric
ciotique qui vous a déchu de votre poste
de numéro 2 des républicains jusqu'où
allez vous faire cavalier seul on voit
cela dans l'invitation de Clément
pervaud et on en parle ensemble juste
après regardez
si on vous invite Aurélien Pradier c'est
parce que vous l'avez un peu cherché
l'attention médiatique la lumière est au
centre du jeu vous aimez ça à force de
sortir du rang d'affirmer votre liberté
de ton et d'action vous êtes passé de
l'enfant prodige à l'enfant terrible de
votre famille politique les républicains
conseillé général à 21 ans député du Lot
à 31 ans vice-président des républicains
à 36 ans
brusquement déni de vos fonctions
[Musique]
moins de trois mois plus tard par Eric
Ciotti
si nous arrachons cela il vous reproche
un cavalier seul sur la réforme des
retraites ces prises de position
répétées n'étaient plus conformes avec
les valeurs de cohérence d'unités et de
rassemblement qui doivent guider la
droite républicaine l'aventure
personnelle dans une situation aussi
grave pour notre pays ne peut se
substituer à l'action collective et à
l'esprit de responsabilité pendant
l'examen du texte vous avez été
omniprésent dans l'hémicycle et dans les
médias alors que votre groupe
parlementaire avait négocié un accord
avec le gouvernement vous n'avez eu de
cesse d'alerter sur ce que vous appelez
vos lignes rouges les lignes rouges les
lignes rouges les lignes rouges c'est
une ligne rouge les lignes rouges cette
ligne rouge cette ligne rouge vous
m'avez entendu poser une ligne rouge
parmi ces fameuses lignes rouges le sort
de ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
avant 21 ans pour vous ils n'ont aucune
raison de cotiser plus longtemps que les
autres comme le prévoit le texte dans
certains cas on va demander à ceux qui
travaillent le plus dur de travailler
une année de plus pour les autres c'est
insupportable je souhaite que la durée
de cotisation l'emporte sur l'âge légal
pour tous ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler avec 20 ans avant même la
décision d'Éric Ciotti ce message ainsi
martelé à l'envie à agacer autant qu'il
a convaincu vos camarades du groupe LR
mais à force de vouloir toujours pousser
l'avantage je pense qu'à un moment
risque le claquage c'est simplement ça
mais pour autant ça enlève pas le talent
de pas avoir Aurélien bradier mais je
pense qu'à un moment il faut simplement
savoir s'arrêter dans le cas d'une
négociation c'est vrai que chez Aurélien
il y a quand même eu un peu d'insistance
forte à un moment où je crois
sincèrement comme beaucoup de collègues
on était arrivé un vrai point
d'équilibre Aurélia la page où est perso
Aurélien il a voulu obtenir des réponses
et des réponses claires certains Éric
Ciotti Olivier Marleix Bruno Retailleau
ont peut-être
dilée un peu trop tôt figure de proue
d'une droite dite sociale vos prises de
position vous ont valu pendant les
débats quelques applaudissements de
députés de la nupesse alors Aurélien
Pradier on vous pose la question ce soir
êtes-vous de gauche
réponse Aurélien Pradier non je suis de
droite d'une droite qu'on a peut-être un
peu oublié qui est celle pour laquelle
je me suis engagé en politique quand
j'étais tout jeune qu'il a le droit de
Philippe Seguin qui essaie de droite qui
a toujours été attentif à tous les
Français je n'aurais pas fait de
politique si et singulièrement à droite
si la droite pour laquelle je me suis
engagé n'avait pas su tendre la main à
ceux qui travaillaient plus dur pour
qu'il a vie était parfois un peu
difficile alors vous êtes de droite mais
ce que vous êtes à l'aise aujourd'hui
vous n'avez plus de responsabilité vous
pouvez plus vraiment peser sur la ligne
numéro 2 c'est quand même un poste
important vous n'êtes pas seul non j'ai
perdu une étiquette j'ai peut-être gagné
d'abord un peu de liberté la liberté
c'est une force en politique j'ai gagné
peut-être un peu de respect
unique non souvent on a pensé ça mais
l'objectif n'était pas de me faire
connaître en tous les cas si ma parole
aujourd'hui est plus entendue c'est pour
mieux mener les combats que je mène et
au fond le seul combat que j'ai mené
dans cette réforme c'est le combat des
carrières longues sur lequel nous avons
obtenu plusieurs gain de cause déjà le
fait que ceux qui ont commencé à 17 ans
n'est pas une année de plus à cotisée
que ceux qui ont commencé entre 20 et 21
ans bénéficient du dispositif de
carrière longue objectivement si je
n'avais 43 ans pour toutes les carrières
longues de 16 à 20 ans et ça vous ne
l'avez pas obtenu et manifestement au
Sénat parlons du fond de la réforme ça
ne passera pas je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas pour deux raisons d'abord parce que
c'est un justice là elle est criante
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que le dispositif de carrière
longue fait que certains vont devoir
cotiser une année de plus que ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler plus tard
personne ne peut justifier cela et parmi
tous ceux qui commentent aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas trouvé une seule personne pour
me dire il est juste que celui qui a
commencé à travailler à 16 ans on fasse
une année de cotisation de plus que
celui qui a commencé à n'a pas ce
discours là pourquoi il reprend pas
cette proposition de 43 ans pour toutes
les carrières à longueur on l'entend pas
là-dessus non c'est vrai mais il n'y a
pas de raison qu'on l'entende pas pour
une raison très simple c'est que la
motion qui a été votée par le bureau des
républicains que je n'ai même pas voté
parce que j'ai pas voulu participer à
cette motion qui a été votée par et
d'autres dit clairement noir sur blanc
que le vote des républicains est
conditionné au fait que les carrières
longues ne doivent pas cotiser plus de
43 annuités il est vrai que on a un peu
personnalisé le combat parce que j'étais
très présent et qu'il faut bien que
quelqu'un fasse feu plus que les autres
que vous étiez candidats à le porter
aussi vous l'assumez oui bien sûr j'ai
une question toute simple si le débat
dans l'hémicycle avait été à son terme
au moins jusqu'à l'article 7 vous
l'auriez voté ou pas le recul de l'âge
légal la position a toujours été à 64 si
nous avions obtenu gain de cause sur les
carrières longues j'aurais voté le texte
et d'ailleurs je ne désespère pas de
cela je pose la question parce que c'est
difficile de vous suivre vous avez quand
vous étiez porte-parole dans la campagne
de Valérie Pécresse défendue les 65 ans
c'est son programme ensuite vous avez
dit la bonne réforme c'est celle qui
allonge la durée de cotisation là vous
nous dites avec les carrières longues je
vote l'article 7 donc qui a une mesure
d'âge c'est pas clair je vais essayer de
le clarifier dès l'origine je n'ai pas
contesté la mesure d'âge d'abord lorsque
vous êtes porte-parole d'une candidate à
la présidentielle vous n'avez pas la
liberté que je peux avoir davantage
aujourd'hui j'étais un jeune député il
normal que lorsqu'on arrive j'ai pas une
voix aussi on s'y portante qu'elle peut
être aujourd'hui plus ça va c'était pas
assez longtemps que ça non mais plus ça
va pour tout vous dire plus je dessine
aussi les contours de ma propre vision
de notre pays que je ne dessinerai pas
seul mais il est normal que en politique
comprenne son émancipation il n'y a pas
de contradiction entre le recul d'une
mesure d'âge et la prise en compte des
carrément que j'ai toujours défendu
l'homme peut parfaitement aller avec
l'autre m'avez-vous entendu une seule
fois dire que je voulais revenir à 62
ans âge légal mais vous avez dit très
clairement que vous souhaitiez une
réforme par l'allongement de la langue
Touraine sur la durée de cotisation sans
mesure d'âge donc rester au 62 ans
en réalité je pense que la bonne réforme
des retraites c'est celle qui joue sur
la durée de cotisation et voyez-vous le
moment que ça rapporte moins d'argent
que avec une mesure où vous connaissez
cet objectif de déficit public d'abord
qu'est-ce que nous voulons faire avec
une réforme des retraites presque une
réforme des retraites doit être une
réforme pour renflouer les caisses de la
nation je ne le crois pas il y a tant
d'autres sujets sur lequel nous devons
faire des efforts de finance publique
puis une deuxième question dont on ne
parle pas aujourd'hui c'est le fait que
reporter l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite a aussi des effets collatéraux
par exemple 8 milliards d'euros chaque
année consacré aux pensions d'invalidité
lorsque je défends les carrières longues
je défends une certaine conception du
travail et de l'effort qui correspond à
la droite et je défends aussi une mesure
qui évitera demain d'avoir d'autres
dépenses notamment les pensions
d'invalidité tout ça me paraît cohérent
on va parler du Sénat parce que là le
texte a été adopté en commission ces
feutrés c'est efficace et c'est apaisé
on regrette pas d'être député après le
pugilat dans l'hémicycle mais pas envie
d'être sénateur non pas particulièrement
mais j'ai un profond respect pour pour
le Sénat et pour les sénateurs
simplement nous sommes deux chambres
différentes et je ne pense pas qu'il
faille mettre en concurrence l'une et
l'autre j'ai dit il y a quelques années
je ne sais pas en tous les cas je mets
en garde tout le monde dans le débat
public personne n'a intérêt à considérer
que le Sénat pourrait écraser
l'Assemblée ou que l'assemblée pourrait
écraser le sel ce n'est pas notre modèle
institutionnel j'ai dit il y a quelques
heures que le Sénat ne représentait pas
le peuple parfois on entend des heures
certains ont dit mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'est cette insulte au
sénateur pas du tout c'est notre
Constitution et sénateurs ont un rôle
immense celui de représenter les
collectivités les territoires
l'assemblée d'universel pour l'Assemblée
nationale
sont aussi légitimes que les députés
simplement que chacun est bien à
l'esprit qu'il y a un grand danger à
faire adopter une réforme des retraites
sans qu'elle ait pu être véritablement
débattu par les représentants du peuple
je crois qu'à la fin des fins si cette
réforme des retraites était adoptée dans
des conditions qui ne sont pas des
conditions pleines et accomplies de
notre démocratie alors nous aurons un
problème que et sénateurs et député nous
auront à gérer voilà ce que je continue
à dire en traçant pas un chemin
personnel un
côté Sénat et les républicains sur
l'extinction des régimes spéciaux aller
plus vite mettre la fin à la clause du
grand-père pour que pour qu'on accélère
l'extinction des régimes spéciaux je
pose la question parce que là ça
déséquilibre totalement les fondamentaux
de la réforme ça doit coûter très cher
vous y croyez vous à cette mesure vous
croyez que le gouvernement va la
reprendre et l'assemblée ce qui est très
étrange dans cette réforme c'est le jeu
de dupe des uns des autres vous savez
c'est quand même très curieux que
l'essentiel des mesures de cette réforme
soient discutées et négocier en dehors
de l'Assemblée et du Sénat c'est pour ça
que dès le début j'ai dit y compris à
mes propres amis politiques au risque de
devoir payer les frais d'une liberté que
on ne pouvait pas négocier en catimini
un accord avec le gouvernement d'abord
parce que je ne suis pas macroniste et
que je n'ai pas envie d'être et que pour
moi c'était à l'Assemblée nationale au
Parlement que les mesures doivent être
adoptées débattues et pour cela il faut
batailler le tempérament politique c'est
aussi la hauteur des convictions que
l'on a on a pas petite question
politique les macronistes et que vous
limite candidats on le rappelle on le
rappelle pas si souvent que ça ou
législatives en 2022 vous n'avez pas eu
de candidats macronistes Renaissance
contre vous et d'une certaine façon quel
ingratitude parce que ça vous a quand
même largement faciliter la tâche pour
être traîner les macronistes n'ont pas
eu de candidats Richard Ferrand l'a
expliqué il y a quelques semaines après
que certains aient supposé que on avait
fait ça pour me faciliter la tâche il se
trouve qu'il y a eu un candidat
macroniste investi par le parti
présidentiel qui s'est dégonflé au
dernier moment il y avait un autre
candidat j'avais en face de moi qui est
un Macron compatible un candidat
socialiste qui avait vocation à devenir
macroniste donc j'ai eu bien
il savait dès l'origine que je n'étais
pas macroniste que je ne devais pas le
devenir parce que ce n'est pas le projet
politique qui est le mien et je suis
heureux d'avoir assemblé plus de 64% des
Lotois au deuxième tour
une minute à peine qu'est-ce que vous
avez compris des attentes des
agriculteurs ont parlé énormément
évidemment de la sécheresse 32 32 jours
sans pluie
sécheresse en hiver ils veulent des
nouveaux moyens d'irrigation des
retenues d'eau il faut y aller quitte à
relancé la guerre des méga bastines la
question nous est une question
absolument gigantesque j'en ai beaucoup
parlé dans les mois passés on aurait pu
parler de la question l'eau pour
l'Afrique on peut parler de la question
de l'eau pour notre pays sont les
retenus d'eau pas les méga bassines
nécessairement mais des petites retenues
colinéaires qui permettent d'irriguer
c'est le retraitement des eaux usées
Israël retraite plus de 90% de ses eaux
usées pour l'agriculture en France c'est
moins d'1%. c'est cette gestion de l'eau
Georges Pompidou en parlait déjà il y a
de nombreuses décennies le défi de l'eau
est un défi français européen mondial de
première mesure et je souhaite que nous
ayons dans notre pays un débat
absolument prioritaire sur l'eau parce
que c'est de là que découleront toutes
les grandes politiques publiques de
l'avenir notamment l'abondance sur l'eau
il a eu raison d'utiliser cette
expression là le président français le
mot surement mais que faisons-nous il
n'y a pas de fatalité on a beaucoup
d'innovations
un plan qui sera annoncé il y a beaucoup
d'innovations à produire en matière
d'accès à l'eau repenser la question
l'eau qui est une question culturelle
dans notre propre pays voilà ce que les
agriculteurs m'ont dit tout à l'heure en
me rappelant aussi qu'ils avaient un des
plus beaux métiers du monde et que
parfois nous avions tendance à l'oublier
merci beaucoup Aurélien Pradier vous
restez avec moi c'est la dernière partie
de l'émission maintenant les affranchis
et leur parti pris on les accueille tout
de suite
deux garçons une fille ce soir bonsoir
Jean-Rémy Baudot de France Info le
président des bonnes nouvelles c'est la
partition qui essaie de jouer Emmanuel
Macron bonsoir Brandon bonsoir
inévitable de Noël le Greg mais on
commence avec Bourbon Express comme
chaque soir l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous a raconté ce soir par
exemple en magasin bonsoir Elsa bonsoir
alors je vais pas parler de la droite je
vais parler de la gauche et l'histoire
du soir je vais la commencer par une
image regardez cette image c'était il y
a trois semaines l'arrivée des députés
de la nuque au Palais Bourbon j'ai mis
en gros la date pour bien montrer que
c'était une archive il s'apprêtait à
livrer le combat contre la réforme des
retraites ils étaient soudés je peux
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas
franchement le cas en cause et bien deux
semaines de débats ou le avec des
insoumis tout feu tout flamme ou tout
bruit tout fourreur tout fureur des
partenaires qui se désolidarisent
publiquement du comportement des députés
une différence stratégique sur faut-il
aller ou non à l'article 7 Jean-Luc qui
s'en mêlent bref deux semaines ou malgré
un objectif commun ils ont montré un
visage divisé alors ce matin Elsa
s'était rentrée des classes oui rentrez
des classes avec thérapie de groupe
réunion intergroupe avec des
représentants des quatre groupes des
insoumis des socialistes des écologistes
et des communistes évidemment nous on a
voulu savoir ce qui s'était dit lors de
cette réunion on a posé la question en
conférence de presse des insoumis
ou évidemment on a fait une sorte de
bilan perspective sur la séquence
retraite le débat était très serein très
avec des points qui étaient les points
de tension qui ont été énoncés et des
points aussi de fierté c'est normal vous
savez on est une jeune un jeune
regroupement là nous pèse ça n'existait
pas avant les Législatives donc c'est
normal que voilà il faille trouver ces
marques partout voilà très prudent
aujourd'hui chez la nupette on est allé
voir évidemment les partenaires les
socialistes notamment on dit qu'il y
aura un avant et un après réforme des
retraites mais on essaye aussi de
dédramatiser
est-ce que ce matin avec les insoumis
vous avez quand même ému un peu une
explication texte sur les divisions que
vous avez eu pendant cette réforme alors
de ce que de ce que nous en dit ce qui
ont participé pour le groupe socialiste
les choses ont été dites vraiment sans
tabou et voilà donc on espère que
puisque tout le monde a l'air de bonne
volonté pour travailler autrement on
espère avoir été entendu mais la nupet
c'est pas en danger alors pour moi la
nupesse est pas en danger côté
communiste les porte-parole n'avaient
pas franchement envie de la prendre la
parole sur ce sujet on a quand même
réussi à convaincre Sébastien Jumel de
nous dire ce qu'il en pensait est-ce que
vous pensez que les différents
stratégies que vous avez eu ça va
laisser des traces dans l'unité de la
nuque
surtout des modalités de réflexion en
commun pour pour être meilleur pour être
plus efficace pour crédibiliser
l'alternative parce que c'est ça dont il
s'agit moi j'ai une formule
quelle que soit les circonstances
ne pas jeter la nuque avec l'eau du bain
et ne pas se noyer dans les bancs de la
nuque ça vous embête que les
journalistes vous posent des questions
là-dessus ça m'embête pas mais en fait
c'est intéressant moi je veux intéressé
aujourd'hui pour me mobiliser pour
exiger le retrait d'un projet qui va
mettre en place un impôt sur la vie la
réforme des retraites
non est-ce que les choses vont changer
est-ce que les insoumis vous revoir
d'ailleurs leur fonctionnement alors
pour l'instant ce qui a été acté ce
matin c'est de faire plus de réunions
avec tous les députés de la nupes donc
si certains voulaient un acte 2 on en
est franchement pas à ce niveau là mais
je vous le rappelle Myriam et ça peut
éclairer les choses il y a un rapport de
force aussi au sein de la nupes regardez
les effectifs des députés les insoumis à
eux seuls ils en ont 74 ils représentent
quasiment et bien les trois autres
groupes réunies évidemment ils sont donc
dans un rapport de force favorable mais
attention les insoumis ils ne sont pas
tous sur la même ligne et de la vue
d'une députée socialiste c'est pas
forcément les critiques des partenaires
qui les feront bouger mais plutôt des
critiques en interne parce qu'il
commence à y en avoir vous les mettez
dans le même paquet ou les parties de la
nupesse et la manière dont ils ont mené
ce débat sur les retraites ou pas ils
appartiennent à une formation collective
donc c'est un peu facile de se des
responsabiliser les uns des autres moi
je pense que ils n'ont pas été à la
hauteur du peuple ce qui est un problème
pour un mouvement qui se dit populaire
je
je considère qu'il y a des batailles qui
sont transpartisanes et puis il faut
rajouter à ce même moment j'ai été
applaudit y compris par le rassemblement
national ce qui n'est pas une meilleure
gloire peut-être mais aussi par une
partie de la majorité puisque le groupe
horizon avait à ce moment-là déposé le
même amendement que moi et puis c'est
pas la première fois dans l'hémicycle on
arrive à mettre d'accord beaucoup de
monde sur des causes communes sans ça on
ne ferait pas voter de textes de loi non
il n'y a pas d'applaudissement honteux
il y avait simplement une mise en scène
je suis pas certain que les députés de
la nupestre ne met pas applaudi y
compris pour aggraver mon cas c'est le
cadeau empoisonné pour vous peut-être
mais ce qui vous a valu vous croyez
votre éviction non j'espère que ce ne
sont pas des mouvements d'humeur comme
cela qui font cette éviction les
insoumis les électeurs vous leur tendez
la main vous pensez qu'on peut basculer
dans votre Mélenchon un vote LR ou c'est
inconcevable ce que je conteste
fermement c'est le raisonnement en part
de marché électoral qui parfois a dominé
dans ma famille politique qui fait que
il y a des Français qui seraient au fond
perdu pour la cause j'ai entendu
certaines mes amis politiques il y a
quelques temps dire il y a plus un seul
lecteur à récupérer chez Marine Le Pen
chez Jean-Luc Mélenchon ou chez les
abstentionnistes c'est une erreur grave
d'abord de tactique politique et
démocratique il faut que nous repions à
tous les Français et la Droite populaire
pour laquelle je plaide avec mes amis
c'est celle-ci c'est celle qui repart à
tous ces Français qui souvent ont des
blessures communes quel que soit
l'orientation électorale qui est la leur
le jour où l'on abandonne l'idée même de
reparler à tous les Français il faut
faire autre chose que de la politique on
va parler d'un sujet extrêmement
concernant à présent avec vous genre ami
Baudot ce mardi Emmanuel Macron a
annoncé la généralisation de la
vaccination contre le papillomavirus
pour les collégiens en 5ème en quoi ce
sujet politique alors rappelons déjà
l'objectif éradiquer les cancers liés au
papillomavirus il y a notamment le col
le cancer du col de l'utérus milmorte
par an c'est peu mais ces cancers ils
touchent aussi bien les hommes que les
femmes 6000 cancers parents qui
pourraient en réalité être évité il est
fondamental de se prémunir donc de
vacciner les jeunes générations si j'en
parle dans cette chronique c'est que ce
sujet mais en lumière le retard de la
France dans la prévention rappelons que
par exemple en Australie tous ces
cancers ont été quasiment éradiqués
grâce à une politique de prévention très
très active donc c'est la clé la
prévention oui et ça tombe bien on a un
ministère de la santé et de la
prévention mais vous avez remarqué
aujourd'hui c'est Emmanuel Macron qui a
fait les annonces pas François Braun
pourtant si vous voulez quelques
coulisses sachez que ce sujet il était
près depuis longtemps le sujet
papillomavirus il était sur le bureau du
ministre depuis sa prise de poste son
entourage en parle souvent mais le sujet
était comme bloqué le président garde
pour lui les bonnes annonces c'est lui
le chef sourit à membre de cabinet donc
il préempte ce sujet oui d'une certaine
manière alors j'y vois deux raisons déjà
parce que c'est un sujet très concernant
très important et relativement
consensuel à part les antivax vous
trouverez pas grand monde pour dénoncer
cette politique publique ça change des
retraites ou de l'inflation
politiquement c'est tout bénef ensuite
parce qu'il y a quand même une réalité
quand un sujet est porté par le
Président de la République lui-même ça
fait beaucoup plus de bruit ça imprime
mieux comme les communicants rares sont
les ministres qui peuvent se targuer
d'avoir une exposition médiatique et
politique suffisante pour porter
eux-mêmes leurs réformes et puis il faut
voir le contexte dans lequel ça a eu
lieu entre les retraites et l'affaire
Palmade qui saturent les chaînes d'infos
jusqu'à la nausée difficile de faire
émerger d'autres sujets c'est donc pour
ça que le portage présidentiel était
probablement important et Emmanuel
Macron reste le meilleur VRP de sa
politique oui ça fait s'interroger sur
les conséquences institutionnelles de
cette réalité pourquoi le président
doit-il porter lui-même le vaccin contre
les papillomavirus je ne remets pas en
cause le encore une fois le fond de
cette annonce qui va dans le bon sens on
avait déjà trop tardé mais c'est la même
chose pour l'écologie l'éducation
l'égalité homme-femme le président porte
tout ça à quoi servent ces ministres sa
première ministre est-ce que ce sont des
super collaborateurs est-ce que ces cinq
le président porte lui-même toutes les
annonces est-ce que à ce moment-là le
président a l'impression d'être vraiment
au contact des français quand il
rencontre notamment des collégiens à
Jarnac aujourd'hui ça fait beaucoup de
questions en suspens mais je trouve que
la Cinquième République finalement
beaucoup de choses Trappes merci pour
cette excellente chronique Jean-Rémy un
tout petit mot quelques secondes il est
dans son rôle sur le papillomavirus de
la République bonne mesure il faudra pas
oublier qu'on a plus de médecine
scolaire qu'on a complètement détruit ce
qu'il faisait la santé publique dans nos
écoles et nos établissements scolaires
qui sont un sujet gigantesque ceux qui
vont vacciner iront dans les dans les
établies mais il va falloir qu'on
reconstruise tout ce qui a fait la
grandeur de notre pays y compris dans
notre éducation nationale qui était
notamment la médecine scolaire et je
lance un appel pour qu'on rebapisse la
médecine Nicolas votre question en fait
elle est importante c'est qu'on voit
qu'on est à un moment où moi le
président de la République a une prise
sur le réel sur les grandes réformes
plus il va faire de la communication
ponctuelle je pense pas que ce soit bon
aussi
inéluctable raisonnable de Noël au
gratte le patron de la FFF oui le patron
de du football français était devenu sa
position était devenue intenable depuis
depuis quelques semaines notamment suite
à un rapport d'audit diligenté par le
ministère des Sports audit qui a fini
par conclure que le patron du du
football a commencé Noël le Great était
illégitime pour gérer le football
français notamment en raison de ses
comportements des SMS et des gestes
douteux vis-à-vis des femmes des
dérapages sous sa présidence qui sont
légion souvenez-vous de du coup d'envoi
de la saison 2019 du championnat de
France de Ligue 1 pour la première fois
dans l'histoire du football français des
matchs avec été interrompus à cause de
cris et de banderoles homophobe dans les
tribunes une décision saluée par la
ministre des Sports Roxana racine à nous
mais le patron du football français
marque contre son camp mais l'arrêt des
matchs ne m'intéresse pas beaucoup
demander aux arbitres de ne plus arrêter
les matchs c'est une erreur on arrête un
match j'arrêterai un match pour décrit
raciste ça c'est clair Noël le grec vous
demande est désormais donc aux Arbites
de ne plus arrêter les matchs en cas de
champ ou de slogans homophobe dans les
tribunes dès la prochaine journée bien
compris
c'est incroyable on l'a bien compris
Noël le grec il avait déjà annoncé la
couleur quelques jours plus tôt dans un
dans une interview dans les colonnes de
Ouest-France il estime ce jour-là qu'on
arrête trop de matchs pour des cris et
des manifestations homophobes dans les
stades face aux multiples réactions
suscitées par ses propos Noël de Grey
rétro comme d'habitude et un an
plus tard donc Noël le grecte fait de
nouveau polémique après cette fois des
propos sur le racisme le 13 septembre
2020 la star brésilienne du
Paris-Saint-Germain Neymar avait accusé
son adversaire marseillais Alvaro
Gonzalez d'insultes lors de la rencontre
du classico PSG OM 12 jours plus tard le
président le Great est interrogé sur ses
actes racistes dans le football mais il
préfère les minimiser sur un match il
peut y avoir des écarts mais on est à
moins d'un pour cent aujourd'hui de
difficultés il y en a eu mais vous savez
quand un black pardonnez-moi marque un
but tout ça des deux bouts donc très
franchement le phénomène racisme dans le
dans le sport et dans le foot en
particulier n'existe pas on peut
des propos étonnants Noël le Great
sachant que quelques mois plus tôt en
Ligue 1 le match Dijon Amiens avait été
interrompu à la suite de créer racistes
visant un joueur noir à miénois et en
2022 en octobre à un mois du début de la
Coupe du Monde au Qatar nouveau des
rappeurs de l'émission Complément
d'enquête Noël le Grey est interrogé par
les journalistes qui lui soumettent des
images on voit des logements des
employés de l'hôtel qui accueillit les
Bleus des pièces insalubre infectées de
cafards alors que répond le président de
la Fédération française de football il
dit ceci ce n'est pas un soluble c'est
un coup de peinture il y a encore du
temps de réparer cela c'est qu'une image
que vous montrez avec deux réchauds à
gaz qui sont peut-être à changer la
séquence vous l'imaginez bien suscite
l'indignation réponse de la ministre des
Sports qui dit cette réaction m'a choqué
j'ai trouvé qu'elle était hors-sol et
comme à son habitude Noël le Great
revient sur ses propos polémique il dit
c'est une vraie maladresse j'en conviens
une maladresse de plus et pourtant
aujourd'hui on l'a appris Noël de great
déchu le patron des cheveux rebondi avec
un nouveau poste à la Fédération
Française la Fédération internationale
de football la FIFA 10 secondes à peine
pour réagir je pense ne regretterai pas
j'ai trouvé indigne à bien des occasions
ce qui aujourd'hui me stupéfait c'est le
fait qu'il ait pu être recazé la FIFA
voilà je pense que là le sport et le
football en particulier n'en sort pas
grandi merci infiniment vous l'avez
compris on est un petit peu en retard
très bonne soirée à tous et à demain
merci à vous merci à vous
[Musique]